facebook est le maître incontesté des
réseaux sociaux
mais ce règne sa compagne une vague sans
cesse croissante de critiques de plus en
plus acerbes la politique de modération
de ce géant du web est au centre de bien
des reproches partout dans le monde des
voix se sont élevées pour déplorer le
trop grand laxisme de l'entreprise de
mark zuckerberg façon discours haineux
et à la désinformation
attaqué de toutes parts facebook s'est
dotée d'un conseil de surveillance une
sorte de cour suprême un organisme se
voulant indépendant et qui sera appelé à
formuler des recommandations que
facebook sera libre d'appliquer ou non
jeff facebook qui se dote d'une sorte de
cour suprême on va regarder ça de plus
près à quoi ça consiste mais c'est un
groupe que facebook a mis sur pied un
organisme indépendant de facebook qui va
examiner les plaintes par rapport à ces
politiques d'utilisation par exemple si
facebook décide de retirer une
publication la personne dont la
publication était retiré va pouvoir
porter plainte au togo auprès de cette
course pro - comme une course vraiment
d'un état on va entendre les arguments y
la cour suprême exposé de pencher de
dire oui
facebook avait raison de retirer sa ou
non facebook devait pas raison il est
recommandé que ça soit remise en ligne
donc c'est un mécanisme dans le fond
pour répondre à ces plaintes le ils ont
mis sur pied cet organe est ce le comte
bon toute une brochette d'experts de
partout dans le monde des gens avec des
profils comme il ya des avocats là
dedans des experts en droits
fondamentaux des gens qui travaillent au
sein des ong
donc un profil quand même assez
diversifiée et d'un peu partout dans le
monde et ses recommandations qui vont
émaner de ce conseil de cette cour
suprême est ce que facebook a
l'obligation les appliquer il ya une
certaine volonté de les appliquer ou
mais je pense pas que de mécanismes
automatiques où chaque décision est
automatiquement appliqué par facebook
puis d'ailleurs la cour suprême en
question va avoir des décisions quand
même assez difficile à prendre un des
premiers dossiers qu'ils vont sur
lesquels ils vont se pencher
c'est à savoir est ce que facebook avait
raison de supprimer le compte de
l'ancien président des états unis dans
l'option une question extrêmement
épineuse aux états unis d'ailleurs un
excellent article qui couvre toute la
jeunesse de ce groupe
puis on voit que dès le départ le dès
les premiers les premières sessions
d'idéation qui ont mené à la création de
ce bureau leur bain il y avait des
chicanes
donc c'est une question qui est
extrêmement politique à savoir qu'ils
ont ce pouvoir un homme laddh de
trancher même la formation même de ce
bureau là ben c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement politique et ça fait pas
le consensus
juste pour qu'on comprenne bien là et on
fait appel à cet organisme l'aplomb cour
suprême
jusqu'à il ya des retraites connu pas
pour faire enlever des contenus qui
existe mais c'est ça qui a été soulevée
c'est une question qui est vraiment
intéressant de ce qui est bon on peut
porter la décision en appel quant au
contenu ce piètre série mais il n'y a
pas de processus inverse donc supposons
que moi je vois une publication
injurieux envers moi je le signale à
facebook facebook décide non non c'est
parfaitement correct on laisse en ligne
je ne peux pas porter en appel à cette
fameuse cour suprême là pour dire non
non vous auriez dû l'effacer donc ça
c'est que c'est quand même un gros
engouement dans le fonctionnement de
sceptre de cet organisme est là et il ya
des gens qui s'inquiètent de voir est ce
que ça devienne une plate forme pour que
les acteurs du web et argumenté devant
ce groupe de personnes pour garder leurs
contenus en ligne alors que les gens qui
jugent que du contenu dangereux en ligne
qui est encore en place n'auront pas
droit lui auront pas accès à ce forum le
donc que ce sera celui ci nature une
toute nouvelle toute nouvelle d'un tout
nouveau mécanisme de la part de facebook
puis comme je disais la décision sur
dans notre chambre ça va très très très
certainement se retrouver à l'émission
car la décision sera prise
vous pouvez compter sur les décrypteurs
pour recouvrir cette décision